the mixture of older cheeses they grind
them up and they add an emulsifier so
that it holds together
[Music]
so my name is Michel tunic on the
research chemist for the US Department
of Agriculture I wrote the book the
science of cheese now there are
pasteurized processed cheeses out there
and that's just a mixture of older
cheeses and fresher cheeses they grind
them up and they add an emulsifier so
that it holds together it's processed in
a way so that it melts easily trade name
for that would be Velveeta for instance
that name comes from the word velvet
meaning the texture what was invented
right before World War one by JL Kraft
who was trying to get rid of some of
those older cheese's so he mix it with
the newer cheese's and came up with
Kraft American cheese
ever since then cheese companies have
been doing that kind of thing it is
legal food and drug administration has
some rules regarding what it can be
labeled as such as pasteurized process
cheese spread and pasteurized processed
cheese food they have to follow certain
moisture and fat limitations and
sometimes they have to be able to melt
at a certain temperature if it falls
outside of those regulations then the
manufacturers can call it some other
things it is something that found a lot
in processed food the Philly
cheesesteaks usually have cheese whiz
melted on them that is a pasteurized
processed cheese so it's something I
would eat too except it's not going to
be nearly as good as a regular natural
cheese
you